chicken stir-fry with rice noodles some
of the best street food of a reason was
in Asia every one of those little
markers was filled with smells of
delicious food that all centered around
an Asian staple noodles learn to cook
those properly and we surprised how
quick and easy it is to knock off a
delicious dinner first off you're gonna
soak our noodles now these are rice
noodles into a bowl and just pour hot
water over the rice noodles soak and
rehydrate 12 to 15 minutes to soften up
if you've got to walk perfect if not
just a normal sized frying pan with big
sloping sides pan on get it really nice
and hot chicken breasts
Faline hardly any fat on there you've
got this little Phillips just slice that
off now the secret to getting it really
nice and thin and to cut it into strips
take your knife keep it nice and flat on
the board and sort of slice it in half
like a sort of scholar like that we call
this butterfly in the chicken take a
rolling pin and place then gently roll
over the chicken what it does it sort of
flattens it allows you to slice it even
thinner and the thinner a slice of the
chicken sort of crisper it gets the
quicker it cooks slice it in half to
start slicing these nice thin slices and
the good news is one chicken breast can
serve two or three easily next wash your
knife and finally slice garlic
the thinner the garlic the crispier this
is a young tender broccoli just slice
them down what a bites to the broccoli
and normally you sort of paste the dish
with 1/3 noodles 1/3 vegetables on 1/3
of your protein chicken with a dish that
takes literally minutes to put together
it's really important to get everything
organized everything needs to beat your
fingertips touch of olive oil pan really
nice and ready just starting to smoke
drop the chicken in first just salt
pepper open up those little strands of
chicken
[Music]
nice
once we started to sear off the chicken
get the garlic in let that get really
nice and crispy and the way to do it is
this sort of spread with chicken the
garlic at the side of the pan you see
why it's so important to cut the chicken
into thin strips because it colors and
cooks at the same time as well really
really crucial
now that garlic get really nice and
crispy rocking in feel strange putting
raw broccoli in like that normally the
blanch in boiling water dry however not
that crunch now slow sauce that helps to
season it but also stains beautifully
soy sauce in
lovely
except what I want I figured out
[Music]
give me a pan a little wipeout a
teaspoon of olive oil get that what
really nice the oil again drain your
noodles
a beautiful this is a really exciting
way of finishing this quick stir-fry
very classic two eggs in whisk up the
eggs and give that a really good whisk
[Music]
sort of almost spread it by the side of
the pan lightly seasoned the eggs
noodles in chicken and broccoli in and
give that a really nice mix and want the
egg to sort of almost bring the dish
together that eggs cooked
[Music]
make sure you got that nice the even
distribution of chicken broccoli garlic
lovely I just finished that that fresh
line and they have a very simple
delicious stir-fry with rice noodles
[Music]
you'll find my next fast-food classic
all over America tasty chili dogs for
[Music]
super quick and easy beef chili add
chopped onions to hot olive oil and cook
until soft then add chopped garlic a
teaspoon of cumin seeds and stir to
release their lovely aromatic flavor
next chili powder turn up the heat and
break beef mince into the pan ground and
season
add tomato puree and cook through
next add lager spice tea Worcestershire
sauce chopped in tomatoes
dried oregano
at a sprinkle of sugar
[Music]
cook frankfurter or bratwurst sausages
bung in a bun and simply top with the
spicy beef chili
easy and irresistible a dog worth
crossing the street for my third Street
food inspired recipe is Vietnamese style
baguette with beef
[Music]
start slicing certainly steak into
strips then simply marinate in soy sauce
the salty and runny honey the sweet and
leave up to two hours then thread your
marinated beef strips onto skewers and
pan fry in hot olive oil for the topping
which adds a lovely sour contrast break
carrot and simply leave to pickle in
rice vinegar
[Music]
next make the easy dressing simply DC's
and chop a Chile add caster sugar and
lime juice add a glug of fish sauce
[Music]
slice that forget when lovely and brown
the marinated steak skewers are done
remove and add top with the pickled
carrot add cool sliced cucumber drizzle
over the spicy dressing and to finish it
off add coriander leaves
[Music]
it's simple to make but complex in
flavor absolutely delicious
[Music]
three stunning recipes from the street
to your home guaranteed to take food on
the run to a whole new level smoky pork
sliders with barbecue sauce everyone
loves a burger there are true fast-food
original and that's the exciting thing
about street food you can take an old
classic like that and reinvent it into
something really exciting what do you
think of a burger what you need is a
great sauce and I like smoky barbecue
goes hand in glove with a great burger
start by finely chopping one onion and
three cloves of garlic nice hot pan
tablespoon of olive oil onions and
garlic into the pan a nice seasoning
salt and pepper now the secret of a good
barbecue sauce is that really important
camera zation to begin with a nice 2
tablespoon brown sugar it darkens the
onions but it really starts to sort of
give that nice syrupy body to the sauce
and put a little bit of heat in there
now a nice teaspoon of smoked paprika
that's the important part of working
with spices you've got to cook them out
you always sort of burn off that rawness
especially with a smoked paprika it's
exactly where I want it to go onions and
garlic you free caramelize
side of it you're in would you sat down
now I've got a fantastic smoky base to
complete the sauce I'm making my life
really easy and adding pre-made
Worcester sauce and tomato ketchup cut
that out
for two to three minutes now depending
on how thick you like the barbecue sauce
that term is how long you cook it out
for I don't want it to be too runny but
I don't think either that's the
consistency we're looking for
[Music]
lovely turn on the gas
it's such a season now take that out is
the kind of source that I'd like to have
sort of bottled up in the fridge it's
great for sandwiches but guys Brittany
well with these sliders homemade smoky
barbecue sauce give a panel it white now
start the mix to the sliders to give my
mix a really interesting flavor and
texture I'm gonna be using unsmoked Bank
bacon I travel all over the world and I
spend a lot of time in the States they
know how to make a great slider Tex life
is beef sliders chicken sliders there's
almost like a way of having a burger but
on a much smaller miniature level little
TSP of olive oil on that bacon to get
really nice and crispy bacon in this
just gives the really nice sort of
chunky delicious makes on texture and
pork is perfect for slider and tapash
lot
slots are a lot sweeter than your normal
white onion five five five and now that
Bacon's getting really nice and crispy I
want a bit of heat in there a little
teaspoon smoked paprika in there and we
see these fibers in the states from one
portion there's like four or five of
them a little mini one bite us
incredible
now take your pork just open up and give
it a really nice seen thing so important
you can't season a slider after cooked
it's impossible so seasoned it nicely
baked now it's nice and crispy just take
little touch kitchen roll just drain
that off there nice pat that nice and
dry if I want all that nice sort of
crisp penis in there beautiful mix all
that in take a nice ball and sort of
roll it size of a golf ball get it nice
and round first and then three fingers
just Pat that down don't flap them too
thin otherwise be able to cook and they
go sort of dry
because sliders are bite-sized burgers
designed to go in small buns you don't
want to make them too big yes
[Music]
get a pan nice and hot tablespoon of
olive oil when a slider is literally
that affect about an inch thick we're
going to take two and a half to three
minutes each side in
[Music]
tell them over lovely once you've turned
them tilt the pan and just spoon all
that juice back into them give my mouth
watering huh
very easy to dry the pork out so just
feeling you now you think is nice and
firm the little touch of springiness in
the center and half of those add your
cheese now still gets nicely melted I'm
using wedges of smoked cheddar and it
has that nice sort of salary smokey
creaminess to the slider finely shredded
baby gem lettuce just take those buns
make sure they're sliced
listen evenly take your lettuce quite
generous from the lettuce it's a nice
thin slice of tomato take your burgers
see that cheese
melted the barbecue sauce place the top
on
and that is my version the slider that
is small dynamic but packed full of
flavor I'll take that over Hamburg any
day
[Music]